in rule two you say to imagine who we
could be
and then to aim single-mindedly at that
but reality gets in the way of you
reaching
that potential and it can hurt how
can people cope with the pain of
unreached potential
well part of oh that's a really good
question look
every ideal is a judge
right so you posit an ideal and
instantly you're in inferior position in
relationship to that ideal and that can
be crushing
okay so what do you do about that well
one answer is no ideals
well that's not a good answer because
then you don't have anything to do
right so so and that deprives you of a
main source of pleasure which is
observed uh generated as a consequence
of observed movement towards a valued
goal so
if you have a high goal and you see any
movement towards it there's a potential
there's a really powerful potential kick
there so you don't want to dispense with
that
but then if you set up an ideal it can
judge you very harshly
so then you have to rearrange your
reward
philosophy and instead of punishing
yourself from
as a consequence of perceived distance
you reward yourself for incremental
movement forward
and that's not just theoretical look i
was stopped by three guys on the street
this week
three separate occasions and they all
told me the same thing they you know
they
they said that they had read or
something i wrote or listened to
something
or watched something and that it had
been helpful and whenever
ever anybody says that to me i always
ask them okay exactly what
was helpful and what changed because i
want to know
what's helping so that i can understand
the target and hit it better
and so and generally people are are
pleased to tell me
although sometimes it takes them a while
to formulate exactly the description
but they all three of them said um i
stopped comparing myself
to other people so i'll stop comparing
what i didn't have to what other people
had i left that off the table
and then i started to reward myself for
improving over what i was
yesterday so they and that's profound
change because it means that you
actually get
your reward structure transformed
and that's a big deal because that's
that's your source of positive
emotion and enthusiasm encouragement all
of that so now you can start to
encourage yourself for
for genuine improvement and it's also
pragmatically extremely intelligent
because
incremental improvement repeated is
virtually unstoppable
and i that's like the hallmark of
behavioral therapy
that idea because what a behavior
therapist does is you come and you say
to me i'm not things aren't the way i
want them to be
and then i say well well how would you
like them to be
and how are they not that so we lay out
the problem the territory
and then the next thing we do is lay out
a trajectory
which is okay well here's something
you're lonesome
you don't have a partner okay so what
are the
what are incremental movements can you
make towards that goal
that you would do that would be helpful
and so maybe you you you negotiate with
the person
because that's what you do if you're a
reasonable therapist and you say well
look why don't you uh
you decide as a consequence of the
conversation why don't you write out a
description of yourself for a dating
site don't post it or anything
just write it out and and then let's see
if you actually do that
and so then the person comes back next
week and they say i did that and
not only that i posted it and you say
great what's the next step or they say
geez you know i just kept avoiding that
and then you say okay well we need to
break that down
you avoided it well could you write one
sentence about who you are right now
while you're sitting here
and sometimes they can do that right
away or sometimes they can't and then
you
you make a microanalysis of that and
what you do is you
you reduce the magnitude of the move
forward until you hit the point
where you actually will do it
and that's like the secret to good
negotiation and as well
if you're negotiating with your wife
maybe you want one of her behaviors to
change
and then obviously she has to be on
board with that and
hypothetically that's going to be
reciprocal process
but what you want to do is find a small
improvement that is measurable
that's implementable that will be
implemented that you can then reward
and and that's that's that's how you can
have your ideal
you you can have whatever ideal you want
as long as you're willing
to reduce your movement forward to
achievable increments
but that's okay because they compound
so and i really learned this as a
therapist it was one of the things that
was so fun about being a therapist is
you can take someone through this
process and start them on just the
tiniest goal you know and
it just seems trivial but they'll do it
and then
they start moving fast aft faster and
faster after that point once
once the direction has been established
and people make incredible improvement
over
you know uh not unreasonable spans of
time
a few months maybe a few years but which
is not nothing but it's not
decades you know it's i saw that time
and time again
so aim high but
reward yourself for small incremental
improvements especially ones that repeat
every day i think that's one of the
challenges we have
in the modern era because social media
shows us
the highlight reel of everybody else's
life but we get to watch our own
failings from a front row seat right we
watch ourselves blunder through life
we realize just how far away from our
potential
we are but nobody else actually knows
that
no one else knows the podcast you could
have recorded the business that you
could have built
the book that you could have written in
a very very real sense you are only ever
competing against yourself
but because yes and that's especially
it's absolutely right that's why the
individual
that that's exactly why group
categorization of people is so
dreadfully wrong
it's like you really are your only
comparison group especially as you get
older
because your life is so idiosyncratic
and peculiar that
any compare i mean look you have to care
what other people think it's stupid to
think otherwise
be because you have to be social and you
have to be aware of what other people
are doing and all of that so
it's this is a psychopathic individual
individuality
but it is genuinely true that no one has
your set
of opportunities and limitations
and so the the comparison just isn't
real it can't be sufficiently
multi-dimensional
you know because maybe you see someone
who's re i've dealt with i've
i've met many people who are very very
rich and
you can look at their lives and they
have these huge houses and
material plenty but j and they're
shielded from
many catastrophes that would hit someone
without those resources harder
but their lives are still full of
exactly the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and
so you you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see well the
person's worked 80 hours a week for 40
years and it's blown all his
relationships out of the water it's like
yes he's rich but he's also old
now you know he's 60. and one of the
best predictors of wealth is age
you know really do you want to be young
and poor or old and rich
it's like i'd pick young and poor
because you can't buy youth
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy peace